Back in the old day[s] when I was starting off on YouTube, horror was the only thing I would play.
I would play horror
every single day.
**shits pants**
Now the horror Genre back, then was actually a dying genre. *rest in pepperonis* Although, the big title games like Silent Hill
All of the big title games like Silent Hill, Resident Evil, Fear, Condemned,
Resident Evil, Fear,
These really staple of the genre horror titles
had all turned to action games instead of horror games.
It was really sad to see. And for-- for me, who was trying to make a living, I had to find all these horror games
but they were so few.
And Indie games is really what brought back the horror genre,
Amnesia especially. But there were a few others at the time.
And I remember I could literally count all of them on my hands like it was Bongcheon-dong Ghost, Ao Oni, Exmortis,
*Laughs*
*laughs*
This fuckin point and click game, Witch. [You] guys remember that game?
Nosferatu. I don't even think that was an Indie game.
Nowadays, the amount of horror games is what, hundreds? Thousands?
I remember someone suggested Slender to me five years ago.
And I literally searched [it] up. I'm like, "Woah, this, this game looks amazing,
I can't wait to play it! Has anyone else played it?" And I looked and there was not a single video of it.
And I'm like "Holy shit.
I gotta play this right now,"
And I did, and it went so fucking viral and now, you search Slender in YouTube and there's five million results. *laughs*
And there was one horror game that I could just not get ahold of because it was Korean.
So to play it, you had to *illegally download* which I would never do! I would never do that.
Which is why I never played it, God Dammit, because I am with the law.
And it's called White Day. But now it's out on Steam.
And I thought for good old times sake, let's play this old-ass Korean horror game that now has been ported to Steam.
*Music plays*
I remember watching Cry play this as well, so I know the intro sequence.
*Chuckles*
Are we gonna get some skirt action? I always wondered what the... the actual, eh... story was. *Laughs*
Green grass, the brightly shining sun, and her...
I mean, it looks pretty good.
I mean, it looks pretty good. I like the art style.
I like the art style. I think they did a good job.
This extremely uninteresting. *laughs*
Like, what is this?
*High voice* "Oh, don't take my photo there is the people on it"
*Deep voice*
"Ehy there you like that photo?"
"I can take photo of you" ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
*High voice* "Hi guys, it's me!"
"I gotta go"
*Deep voice*
"Ah shit, Mabel"
That's the story. That is the story right there.
Alright, unless everyone dies in-- Look it's the same f***ing exact tree.
So-young Han, Junior homeroom. She was there.
Wow, what a story mark.
Okay, here we are. Alright, let's play this shit.
You run by pressing space
Okay, I should go to Junior homeroom. Okay--
Oh my God.
Oh my God, just let me f***ing play!
Why do I run with spacebar who the f*** puts running on space bar. I need the key.
Oh yeah, I remember, I think you get the flashlight in here.
Oh yeah, and Korea has this weird-ass fucking toilet things that I'm sitting in. Ew, get out! What the f*** that's disgusting!
*laughs* What the hell...
That's not how you hide man. This is not it.
Come on flashlight. I know you're here somewhere. I remember five years ago.
Come on flashlight.
There's something I needed to do here.
It's too dark? Okay. Alright, fine.
Do you see now b****?
A tip of a pen!
oh wow-- Oh, there it is. There's window.
Oh, cigarettes! I remember your cigarettes. That's right, who put cigarettes in a school disgust-- hey, I look pretty good.
Okay, let's check it-- Oh yeah, there's two bathroom. Okay, alright, cool. Maybe there's--
Maybe there's something here. Huh? Where's my f***ing flashlight, huh?
Surprise! Surprise! Surprise!
Really? Nothing? This door is locked, or..? What's happening?
Oh, what do we got? Another pen? Why the f*** do I need a pen?
My God, what was that sound?
I am so scared right--
If--
What?
*Clock chimes*
Wow, that's fun.
*Loud noise*
What was that? My God, this game is terrifying. I've never been this scared in my life.
*Unknown Noises*
Oh my God. There's someone else at school. This is the scariest game of all time!
Yo, what up b****es! I have your diary.
Oh, I get to choose dialogue and s***! Uh, sorry.
I bet this changes the whole game
I wonder how big his d*** is.
God dammit!
Fine, but I won't like it. I will definitely like it. I want to smash that-- Mmm.
"A guy like me," you hear that? I'm huffing. I'm huffing boy.
You mean giant... nothingness? I got... shoes...
And, uh... buttons. Oh my God, she's-- Yes! I told you! I told you!
Shut the f*** up, man!
I've been here plenty times! I was sniffing the urinal!
She's totally flirting with me. Okay, so we need to get there.
"If you look around the school you'll be able--" shut the f*** up b****. I got you fam. There's a toolbox here.
I remember that s***.
Where's the toolbox, huh? The door, okay.. Where's the toolbox? There you are!
Wooo! Woo woo woo!
And I remember this s***!
You could grab this. Ayy!-- *Phone rings*
Oh.
Shut up. Shut up. Alright which one is calling ..this one?
Well, I guess I missed a call. Mr. Ladder. You're coming with me buddy! Shut the f*** up plants!
Going pretty good so far.
♫ Memories, memories, memories. ♫
♫ They never stop-- ♫
Where the f*** go? There you are, okay. Alright I'll put ladder down here, and then I walk up ladder here
And then I used to bus-- butt cutter. Box cutter.
As you can see here by this animation, I am cutting it.
Oh, wow! That's how it fell off because I cut the glue and here I go. Sayonara, b**** shutter! See you later.
Don't look at my ass.
She's definitely looking at my ass.
Whoa, what's happening?
*Gasp*
Oh my God! Yes! I remember this s***!
Oh, s***! Oh! It's the janitor!
It's the janitor everybody! The crazy janitor. That's the school's janitor.
Just like every school has a janitor that beats people up.
So does this school, Korea.
Not even once. I'm sure that'll have no consequences whatsoever for me
Ah, guessing we can't go there because of hot steam which all school has.
Okay, these are bad op--
Okay, puzzles!
Oh my God, it's a puzzle everybody. Think I can solve it? Let's see here. Uh, turning the valve...
with... will turn off the steam. I must be some sort of genius.
Okay, we only did it to one of them.
That's fine. We'll find the other one.
My God!
That was a extremely difficult task, but I was able to accomplish it.
Thank God. I have such pure swedish "intellectsh." Yes "intellectsh."
Now, I don't know-- the only reason I know to go here, is 'cause we solved the puzzle.
Flashlight would be pretty good.
Oh my God, it's a box! Ahhhh!
Ahh!
Oh, what the f-- It's a demon box. What the f***?
Oh my God, yes.
Yes.
This bell doesn't stop!
Get used to this f***ing bell sound, 'cause it does not f***ing stop.
Oh my God.
Oh, great.
"You can't see anything. It's too dark." How about this giant f***ing demons thing? Is that not lighting it up for you?
Oh, God. Okay, one, two, three, four, five.
What is this? Bioshock?
Which ones need to be connected then?
One.
Oh, I see
It doesn't transfer?
Well, it's impossible for all of them to be connected. Oh my God, this is so annoying!
Alright, there's a--
Oh, okay, so I can read this one! It can be shut down temporarily by connecting the third and the fourth. God dammit.
"Oh I can't see anything except this document!"
Okay, the three and four
Well, I solved it by accident. Jesus Christ. What a great puzzle. Shut up box.
Oh, hell yeah. It just flew out, man. It just it just came right at me, man. It's not my fault, man.
I just turned off the alarm. What a great security system.
Turn off the alarm, the thing just go *grunt*. Hey, we got the homeroom key. Excellent. Now we can open doors and s***.
oh s***, you f***ing creepy-ass b****.
*High pitch* Oh! Aha!
Woohoo! Yaha! Woohoo!
Thanks a lot!
Now lick my pussy!
Nobody likes a salty b****!
*Normal Voice* Main building, first central hallway key
Okay, where is that?
You pondering about life over there, or what's happening?
Yeah
Some deep thoughts. I'll let I'll leave you to it. I'll leave you to it. Don't worry buddy.
I'm just gonna.. I'm just gonna go, um..
F*** if I know! I guess here. This place is creepy, I don't like it
Okay, let's go. Why am I still here? Why am I here? Oh God. That can't be good.
Oh, s***, it's the janitor! It's the janitor! But he has a limp!
Oh, man.
I remember being chased by this f***ing janitor.
What? Oh, you broke the game. B**** I don't care about you. Alright, let's head on out.
What is that-- Oh! What the f*** was that?
You can't just f***ing throw a thing-- Oh s*** it's the janitor!
Oh my God! This is the scariest enemy I have ever seen!
Oh, f***! I'm surrounded!
Ahh!
Why would you hurt me?
Why Elise? Why? I gave you everything! I gave you seven years of my life!
F***!
He's whistled. He's got a whistle
It's okay, I got an old trick up my sleeve: ladder.
Ladder! Ladder!
Ahh!
*Evil Laugh*
*screams*
You f***ing bitch ladder. Oh God, did I not save? Oh God, I don't think I saved.
Okay, I remember now. You press-- you put the demon symbol in the demon symbol hole
Which as you do.
As a demon symbol man.
Of course! Of course, that's how you do it.
Alright, let's go upstairs. F*** the Janitor man. That bald son of a b****.
Okay, we're up here now. This is when the game gets a little confusing I remember.
Can we investigate all the clocks in this game?
Yes, please. You know how much I love clocks.
Dammit, clock!
F*** you. F*** you too, plant. F*** all of you.
What? What's making that sound?
Shut up. Everyone shut up.
Okay, we got another pen.
I'm not scared.
Okay, I'm not scared. I'm not scared, okay?
What?
No!
Oh, it's the janitor! It's the janitor! Not the janitor!
F*** you, janitor!
You bald son of a b****!
God damn, God damn! Oh no! Oh! I gotta use my super move.
Hide.
Ahh!
I-- Oh, we got a document.
Shoot!
I thought you had a limp, man!
Aw, f-- What?
Aw, f***!
F***!
I'm dead. I'm f***ing dead. Are you happy?
Oh, no. How can he run forever?
Hide! Hide, hide, hide, hide, hide! Hide, hide! Hide, hide! Ah, you're beating the s*** out of me!
*Evil Laughing*
Ah!
What the f***? This game is impossible. It's impossible to run away from the janitor. He has a limp. He has a limp.
How is this not even f***ing serious?
How does this f***-- Oh God.
He's coming! Ahh!
*Whistle blows*
Who blows a whistle?
Oh my God. Oh my God.
Oh my God. Oh my God. Oh
Ohhh!
OOOOOOOOOOOOOH *screaming*
He's looking for me! How does he not see me?
He's looking for me. How does he not see me?
Just stand real still. Just stand really still and the--
Oh... Ahh!
He tricked me!
He f***ing faked me! It looked like he was leaving and then he beat the s*** out of me! F*** this game!
My God, that was the scariest- Love letter-
That was the scariest moment of my life!
God damn! F*** the janitor, man! F*** the janitor, man!
*Keys jingle*
Oh, I swear to God, is he gonna co--
*Door rattles*
Oh my God! What is your problem? I am innocent!
Oh look I found the code! 3, 1, 2, 6! Excuse me! Don't kill me!
What did I say? What an idiot.
*Crickets chirping*
Here we go! Finally some progress.
Okay, shut up, game.
3, 1, 2, 6. I pressed it wrong.
3, 1--, 1, 2--
There it is.
Woo! We got the key and a small key as well.
Oh my God, I am so spooked.
This is it. Come on, key--
Yes! I'm f***ing genius!
God dammit! F*** you, janitor!
Janitor! I bet you're not even a real janitor!
You f***ing janitor. You fake-ass b**** janitor.
F***.
There's never anything in these! Never!
Aw, this better be the f***ing exit.
*Strings play*
Oh.
Oh!
That's not the exit!
I don't think this is the exit!
Excuse me lady from The Grudge movie. I think I took the wrong turn!
Into Hell!
Oh. Well that was great. What a nice experience. Oh, she left her school coin. What an idiot.
Oh, we can go in here now!
What the f*** was she doing with that tree? Huh? What that f*** was she doing with that tree?
Wow, things are so much more pleasant here now.
Swear to f***ing God, if I run into the f***ing janitor...
There we go-- Hi!
No, you're seeing me.
Well you need to learn proper grammar. Go back to school.
**Rumbling**
"Ah!"
Aw, hell yeah!
This is where the hentai begins!
You dropped something!
Uh, b****, you dropped something!
Alright, well, I'm just gonna go!
Okay! What a perfect time to end this episode.
A nice little blast from the past.
Finally now I've played them all.
Officially, I played them f***ing all. Was it worth it? Absolutely not.
Have we learned anything? F*** no.
Anyway. I hope you enjoyed this episode.
I had a lot of fun playing. It was fun.
Leave a like if you enjoyed as well. Uh..
Fam Squad Jujitsu, and I'm out.